what the hell is that thing
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is serious you said that if
i came on this trip you would give me
one question
on camera for all the men and women out
there
okay falling for the passion within the
creative visionary yet it be their
impeccable fashion sense
or profound platitudes
deep nothingnesses
that's highly attractive [ __ ] right
there people fall for that
i want you to cut deep remember i'm safe
so you can go cut right to the core it
needs to
i need to feel it i want you to give me
10 reasons why not
to date the phone again thank you to my
friends at storyblocks for sponsoring
this video
oh god i'm sorry up super early this
morning
let me rephrase gabs yanked me out of
bed
super early this morning to tell me that
she's oh my neck's getting sore
ah wait basically gabz told me that she
had been to this mobile home
that i'd be banned from using my phone
camera
laptop and that will be going to a place
where there's absolutely no
wi-fi understandably so because what
i've been doing
is working working in this office
youtube as much as i love it
it's a fraction of what i do i'm still a
very active
film director writer ideator i work on
global campaign
i'm not gonna bore you with the we're
gonna cut straight to the point here so
basically overworking i've just been
it's been a
[ __ ] husband intervention time i guess
from gabs and she threw me this curvy
this morning to say that
if i don't come on this trip with her
asap
we would have to sit down and have a
talk
i hate sitting down and talking so
quickly in it down to my studio
gathered a few essential items and uh i
guess try to sneak them into the car so
that
while we on this getaway trip i could at
least make
an epic piece of content
you rent an entire house or what's going
on
hey baby what's all this stuff
oh like clothes and [ __ ] i packed all
your clothes
maybe this weird thing this is meant to
be no work
trying to just keep one camera one
camera no backup batteries
deal it was at this point in time i came
up with the idea to ask up
one question that would still make a
very entertaining piece of content
we traveled north to a beautiful place
called vivalak where there is literally
no
soul reception so with all transparency
that epic setup montage scene you saw
right up front
was done yesterday when i got given my
camera privilege is back
and was shot right here at home in cape
town
10 reasons why are they more no
i'd have to think about it yeah just off
the top of your head
okay all these reasons gabby mentions
are taken from old behind-the-scenes
footage of me
and somewhat what i guess you would call
filmmaking character defect
god this is embarrassing
none of the furniture in the house ever
seems to have a place where it stays
especially the plants you can do better
than that
okay but it's an eric an earth
i know i never heard of that before so
i'm an earthquake
and that's bad i don't do not want to be
an urger it's like a pet peeve
it's not about jesus i feel like when
normal people go traveling they each
have their own sort of bag with their
things in it
my bag has to be half mine and half
yours
so that you can have full bags for your
gear
yeah that's fair is that an irk
my thing is really disliking cold water
and often i have to get an x before the
shot
so i'm like an uh a forcing urker no
you've definitely never forced me to do
anything for the shot
just polish us
whenever i try and help and assist you
i'm so proud of myself
and then when it comes down to it the
shout is either skew
it's out of focus record hasn't been
pressed
[Music]
how do you feel like you've done a good
job when you haven't even pressed record
there are often times when you like deep
and thought about a film
or something and it can happen even in
the middle of a conversation
and then it's like talking to a brick
wall so i'm just like one
huge earth
taking photos is never just taking
photos
it's always taking like the photo
what do you mean that makes no sense
when your films don't perform the way
that you expect them to perform
then you get all bleak i just i don't
understand i'm like why you're gonna
make another video
anyways who cares how many views it it's
got no views
[ __ ] you forget to leave your director
attitude on set
and you bring it over with you and you
start directing the [ __ ]
that is actually pretty funny that is
one of these things
okay i can see that being very irk
watching really great movies is almost
impossible with you because every couple
of minutes it's paused so you can study
how the shout is done
and think about recreating it and
that's how i learn can you trick me
into thinking that we're going on a long
romantic walk or hike or drive somewhere
and it's actually just so you can get a
time lapse or a shot at something
yeah but ever since my new relationship
with storyblocks
can they be 11 can they be 11. what's
that interrupting to do brand reads
baby the brand reads is what pays for
our dope
trader park live okay so story blocks
has has given me the opportunity
to no longer have to trick you someone
else has done that
to their filmmaker girlfriend or
boyfriend and trick them
into getting the perfect time lapse for
the perfect shot
and i just go along and steal the shot
put it in pretend it was my own and it's
copyright free
life approved see that storybox saved
our relationship okay it's a dope brand
so even with these 10 like um extra eggs
we really do live the most amazing life
we get to travel the world
together at this joey we get to see the
most amazing places
meet the most interesting people spend
time together
no gabs we gotta stick to the story
okay we're dipping behind the curtains
and we're not making a normal
the influencer video okay that sounds
like
like we live the most awesome i mean
we're looking behind the erg curtain
okay
we're showing people it comes with with
herks
so why waste your time and do it
yourself when it's already there there's
so many options
on storyblocks i make use of storyblocks
all the time so
go down to the link in the description
and sign up
today i also forgot to mention it is
super affordable
it's without a doubt the most affordable
subscription plans out there
and it has unlimited downloads just the
thought of that alone i mean
with a library of more than one million
royalty free assets
lastly you know the clickbaity thing
and what we researched about clickbait
is that if it's actually in the video
and it's fully consensual then it's not
clickbait so for the record
i've never been forced to buy you or
anyone into doing
clickbaity thumbnails that i didn't feel
comfortable with
the clickbaity thumbnails are going to
attract new people i'm all for it
because i see how hard you work
and i just want the best so subscribe
now yeah that's good if you like
this video yeah turn in your
notifications below subscribe
watch more of the videos that gabs has a
huge role in she
she does a lot more than than she thinks
she does she's a
amused no back to the earth yes
er earth video she perkishly irks me
into making irk videos
subscribe share like comment
all of the above go follow me
in on that's a lot of things but if you
go and do that jesus that
i mean wow what a whatever
yeah other than that don't forget you're
awesome brew
and i'll see you next week
[Music]
[Music]
you